natalia bryant is opening up about why
she decided not to play college
volleyball after her dad and sister died
the 18 year old model who is currently a
freshman at the university of southern
california gets candid in a new
interview with teen vogue about the
heartbreaking decision explaining that
she always wanted to play division 1
volleyball but that all came to a
screeching halt after her dad kobe
bryant and sister gianna along with
seven others died in a january 2020
helicopter crash on the way to a
basketball tournament natalia explains
quote i quit volleyball after the
accident because a lot was going on at
the time i knew i didn't love volleyball
as much as they loved basketball i'm
okay with that i just wanted to take a
break from it while being a college
athlete is no longer in the teenager's
plans natalia never questioned whether
she would continue her education due in
large part to her mom vanessa bryant
quote for my mom it was really important
for me to go through high school and get
my education especially complete college
too and while her mom encouraged her to
go to college it was her dad who helped
her realize she wanted to major in film
as a parent we want our kids to learn
the model explains that watching movies
was one way she and her dad spent time
together in fact natalya said that after
seeing star wars the rise of skywalker
in 2019 she asked her dad that night to
watch the whole franchise with her a
request he happily obliged quote he was
just letting me play my playlist and jam
out to taylor swift the whole ride back
and talk about star wars too it was so
much fun and all that echoes what
natalia said last week during an
interview with her modeling agency img
my dad and i would always watch like as
many movies as we can and we'd go on
like movie marathons and then we'd also
like analyze as many movies as we can
and we'd like talk about it for months
anywhere we go we just keep talking
about like different films and how like
it reminds us of like where we are oh my
gosh like that architecture reminds me
of like this piece from like this film
so it's just things like that it just
really inspired me and i was like i want
to do this like
forever she added that in 10 years she
wants to follow in kobe's footsteps and
win an oscar i'm not sure for what or
what
oscar category but i definitely think
that's on my list and i definitely i
want to make a film
that's like where i can incorporate
fashion in like those fashion aspects
and i think like combining like my two
passions like that's just amazing
i want to be able to do that the nba
star won an oscar in 2018 for best
animated short film for dear basketball
i did everything for you
because that's what you do when someone
makes you feel as alive as you've made
me feel like gianna when the nominations
came out
you know she told me she said see that
hard work makes the dream work
and though natalia says reflecting on
her dad's life is quote bittersweet it's
something she does often quote i love
talking about my dad i enjoy talking
about him more than it's sad for me it's
a philosophy she shares with her mom in
large part because of natalia's younger
sisters four-year-old bianca and
two-year-old capri quote for my little
sisters we're trying to keep that memory
for them and also just trying to
remember to live out every day the way
they would
you